[Music]
my name is
eric cronstrom with the center for
charter schools at central michigan
university
i'm going to tell you a story about my
first project
after joining the center now this
project was a challenge
but we were able to automate a process
that had been performed
manually for more than a decade on its
own the project was successful
but we turned it into an opportunity to
rethink how the organization
approaches data science this is a story
about the
technology and the techniques we use to
automate a task
that seemed too complex for the
procedural
document generation but more importantly
this is a story about how to make a
difference in an organization
how to build trust and convince
leadership to try the new thing
one of the responsibilities we have as a
charter school authorizer
is to hold our partner schools
accountable for the academic performance
of their students
one of the ways we do this is with the
annual performance report
the annual performance report or apr
is a document that summarizes how well
students in each of our 58 partner
schools are doing academically
in the spirit of transparency these
reports are made
publicly available on the center's
website and they're also
distributed to school boards and other
stakeholders as print booklets
the organization demands high production
values for these documents and they have
to be
absolutely correct and to make no bones
about it
they look good and these publications
are the primary responsibility of my new
job
so try to picture yourself at a job
interview
across the table is your new potential
boss
he's an impressive guy with a phd in
psychometrics
he's explaining how important these
reports are and some of what goes into
making them
but there's a catch these reports that
usually take
months to produce have to go to print in
seven weeks
well it's a quote richard branson if
someone offers you an amazing
opportunity but you're not sure if you
can do it
say yes and learn how to do it later
so how do you make an apr
first things first you have to get your
data
there are a variety of different sources
individual test scores from assessment
vendors
there's student information from the
michigan department of ed
demographic and comparison data from the
state
and other public entities and so on
once you download everything you load it
into the database
sometimes some of it just stays as flat
files
after sourcing all your information you
can start producing the visuals
with excel a school can have up to 23
different visualizations
depending on the grade levels offered
and there are
nine different excel templates that
produce all of the charts and graphs and
tables required by the aprs
at this point any data that actually
made it into the database
gets pulled back out and copied into an
excel
template then you manually output
the correct visuals for each school
validating the numbers as you go
one at a time for 23 visuals per school
for 58 schools now the last link in this
chain
was adobe indesign where the actual
documents get produced
there's a master report template that
gets updated with fresh content every
year
and finally one last script pulls
everything together
to produce one pdf for each school
this is where being a new person helps a
bit
hiring a new team member is an
opportunity to have a fresh set of eyes
who like the proverbial boiled frog
knows right away when they are dropped
into hot water
our tight deadline was also a blessing
in disguise
since we knew there wasn't enough time
to do
things the way they had done before so
with only
six weeks left at this point we sat down
in the conference room and hashed out
our plan
this is a picture i took of the white
board after that meeting
we figured we had three different
potential paths forward
a fully automated solution built on r
and rendering documents with our
markdown or a hybrid solution
where we render the visuals with r
but still use indesign to pull the
documents together
i should note that up until this point
nobody on the team
myself included had used much r
excel was the tool of choice for data
visualization
and most of any real analysis was
performed in sas
so we gave ourselves only a short amount
of time to experiment with r
and if we couldn't have a proof of
concept for
production-ready visuals in 10 days we
would use excel
and if within a month we couldn't have
an our markdown report that met
our publication standards we would use
the indesign templates
like i said i hadn't used much r up
until this point
i was comfortable with programming my
background is in software development
and automation
i had some exposure to r just through my
graduate coursework
but the only r markdown reports i ever
created were
academic white papers and looking back
i think it was this discussion about the
risks involved
and being open and honest about what i
knew and what i
didn't know and having a backup plan is
how i was able to convince the team to
try something new
now that we had a plan and we convinced
the organization to let us experiment
we set out to recreate this report from
the ground up
and the first thing we needed to do was
prove to ourselves that we could create
a publication
that adheres to our identity standards
using our markdown
and there was one issue that almost
stopped us right away
so at this point in my career i had been
writing code
professionally for 10 years i've taught
web development courses i've taught
database design at a graduate level
the single issue i spent the most time
on for this report
was getting a box with our cmu maroon
background color
with white text using a custom font
in latex maybe that just stands out
as the most difficult technical
challenge
because almost everything else was done
with ggplot and ggplot is amazing
regardless it's not my proudest moment
more seriously though the reason this
process
had been performed manually for so long
is that each school is a little
different
different schools offer different grade
levels
some of our schools are k through 12
some are
just high schools and some are
kindergarten through third grade
and beyond that we evaluate the academic
performance of our schools
based on the terms laid out in their
individual contracts
the educational goals of many of our
schools are
similar but some are operating under
unique circumstances
and all of those differences need to be
represented in the annual performance
report
when you're manually producing visuals
in excel you can
tweak things on the fly to accommodate
all those variations
trying to automate around all that
variability
presents an interesting design challenge
there are two main strategies we employ
to accommodate this
depending on the prevalence of the
variation
and the impact that it has on the report
you can always write flow control logic
into your r code
that so your program will behave
differently depending on what school's
report is currently being rendered
this is okay if it's a unique situation
that only impacts one or two schools
otherwise it can get out of hand quickly
what we try to do first is to generalize
an issue
and develop a data structure that
represents all possible variations
it effectively turns part of a school's
contract
into data a good example of this is
you can have two schools that both offer
instruction at grades
k through eight a school a's contract
stipulates there to be evaluated on the
academic achievement
of their students in grades three
through eight
school b's contract says they are to be
evaluated based on their students in
grades three through 7
excluding grade 8. instead of a giant if
else chain in your code to keep track of
all the contract grades
you can develop a data structure that
represents that information
going through this process we identified
more
problems than we were able to fix right
away
when you have an aggressive timeline you
do what you have to do to get the job
done
and to be fair we only gave ourselves
six weeks to learn ggplot
markdown and latex our code was never
going to be pretty
but i'm proud of what we managed to
accomplish
we met our deadline with a couple days
to spare
the new fully automated reports look
great
with the push of a button an r driver
program renders one report per school
from a single r markdown template and
the best report is it's completely
reproducible
next year we can push the same button
again and get the same reports with
updated data
it is of course until your
communications department
updates their brand identity standards
with new fonts
and new logos and new rules
and such as life so we sent
our reports out to print on time but we
knew we weren't done
we used success with r in this project
to convince the organization to invest
more into our data infrastructure
we just wrapped up the implementation of
our rstudio connect server
and we have time carved out for research
and development
of dashboards and other analytics
projects
my next big project is a plumber api
that will feed data to a web app hosted
on our website
and gone are the days of juggling flat
files between projects
now i access data in my sql server
directly using
r with dbplayer which
i'm convinced works on blackmagic
showing results is what convinced the
organization
to give us the time to invest in
ourselves
we started adopting best practices
around
data management and software development
now
all of the data that we use makes it
into our data warehouse
and each data pipeline has an automated
integration services package
because as it turns out excel was our
etl tool
as well as our database tool and all of
the code and assets needed to build
each solution are stored in one spot in
source control
and we're able to spend more time
building and doing work that we enjoy
because exporting hundreds of charts
from excel
one at a time is super boring and we're
able to spend more time contributing
research
and at a time when research and
education is critical
i hope that our story helps inspire you
to take on your next big project
anyone regardless of tenure or position
or job title can be a leader
you just need to take the first step
you